[音楽]
今日はグラフィックデザイナーの3危険です
突然ですがみなさん
りんごのことを
ご存知でしょうか
a りんご知らないという方挙手をお願いします
皆さんご存知のようですねでは
無知の知という言葉をご存知の方挙手を描いいたします
結構知っておられますねはいじゃあ知らない方のために
無知の知という言葉は実は古代ギリシャの哲学者ソクラテスが
賢者頭のいい方に向かって私は知らないということを知っているというふうに伝えたん
です
賢者はよく言います何か質問をすると知ってる知ってる
それよく知ってるよというふうに言います
ソクラテスは言います私は知らないということを知っている
知っている知っているという方は学ぶ力のない方です
知らない知りたい好奇心のある方は
学ぶ力のある方です
では皆さん本当にリンゴのことをご存知なんでしょうか
子供の頃からリンゴを見たり食べたいっ
もしくはリンゴに触れたりして
りんごのことを知覚してきました
しかし
りんごそのものを本当に認識したり
認知しているのでしょうか
今日はこのリンゴを通してデザインって何っていうことについてお話を進めていきたい
とおもいます
apple
りんごデザインの学び方学び方のデザイン
実は大阪芸術大学でデザインを初めて学ぶ
1年生18歳から19歳の学生に6年前でした
何を教えればいいんだろうというふうにすごく不安になりました
デザインの楽しさや奥深さが体験できて事業をそのものをデザインするような新しい
事業の形をつくってみたいというようなことが自分の中にふつふつと湧いてきました
そこで思い浮かんだのがあったらいいなぁ
こんなデザインの学校というイメージです
僕の頭の中で描かれたのはここにある
このようなってです
それは自然の中でりんご畑の中でまるで科学と芸術が出会うようなそんなイメージが
自分の頭の中に広がったのです
ではなぜリンゴを通してデザインを考えるんでしょうか
皆さんご存知かと思いますがアダムとイブ
りんごを食べて人間になったと言われています
また
このりんごの落ちるのを見て万有引力を発見したというニュートンがいます
そして僕たちの若い頃音楽でビートルズが本当に熱狂させてくれました
アップルレコードを作ったんです
そして
デジタルで革命を起こした iphone ipad といった形で
アップル社のスティーブジョブズがいました
ひょっとするとこの銀後の影に発明や発見があるんじゃないかという仮説を立てたの
です
そして
気づきに気付くという14のプログラムを組み立てました
今日はこのなかから3つのプログラムをご紹介したいと思います
りんご観察長さ
このりんごの周辺の長さを図ろうというふうに学生たちに伝えます
もう1分もしないうちにすぐに手が挙がります
りんごに
ヒモを巻けばいいんじゃないかということを言ってきます
そこで両面テープをしっかりと巻いてそして2ミリの紐を用意してグルグルグルグルと
巻いていきます
まあほぼ15分ぐらいでほとんどの方が負けます
このように巻き上がったリンゴ
まるでオブジェになったことでりんごの歪みというのがすごくよくわかるようになり
ます
これをいろんな視点で観察します上から横から斜めから
このようにリンゴという情報
一つの日も色に入っ
最初にすることによってホルムがしっかりとわかってくるのです
同じものを見ていたのに違うものを見ていた
緑のリンゴも巻いていきます
赤と緑
品種が違うことによって
ずいぶん土地形が違うことに気がついてきます
ヒモを巻く前のリンゴの無数の色や模様がいかに複雑で多様であったかということに
気づいてきます
クロ緑白赤いくつものいるを巻いていきます
そして学生たちはワークショップのすべてを記録していきます
そして
解いた紐の長さを図ろうということですぐに解くことを支持します
このリンゴをもって教室から出ていっ
違う会場で紐の長さを測ってみます
長さを単に数値で判断するのではなく実際に自分の体感として
情報を自分たちの体の中に叩き込んでいきます
この時
11メートル30センチの長さが出ました
もし子もこれ1ミリの日もだったらこの会場の端から端までびゅーーーんと伸びていく
ことになります
体で理解する
続いて
このりんごの面積を測ってみようというふうに学生たちに伝えます
これも1分もかかりません30秒ほどするとりんごの母を向けばいいんじゃないって
言うな声がすぐに上がってきます表面積を測るんです
じゃあ皮を剥いてみようということでまるで家庭科のような授業が始まっていけば
ああああああ
同時にタネの数はとか
断面はといったようなことを観察していきます
学生たちは細かく切ったリンゴの母を
約正方形にして組み立てていきます
そうすると簡単に面積が出てきます
この時の寸法美白32.5平方センチメートルでした
ある学生が言えますリンゴット変わって凄く綺麗
まるでバラの花びらのような美しさだ
じゃあ調べてみようということで調べます
実はリンゴはバラ科だったんです
バラ科リンゴ属落葉高木字です
そしてそれを写真に撮ってちっちゃなパッケージを作ります
上部の空白に文字を入れますアップルと入れます
リンゴジュースのパッケージが仕上がります
次にローズと入れてみます
香水の箱のような明治がみんなの中に飛び込んできます
そしてレッドと入れてみますそうすると赤い粉ものが入っているかのようにみんなに
見えてきます
ローズアップルレッド
概念が見つからない時は名前をつけようというふうに学生たちに言います
名前はリネンの声なんです
そして観念に縛られたら名前を消そうというふうに伝えていきます
名前を付ける名前を消す逆転の発想を繰り返していきます
自分の物差しを作っていきます
続いて3つ目です
りんご観察色
りんごの色を観察しようというふうに学生たちにメッセージします
ルーペを持ってきてりんごの色をジロジロと見ていきます
天面照明を知りといった方に見ていきます
りんごの色は何色ですかってお尋ねするとほとんどの方が赤
もしくは緑と答えられます
しっかりと彼らがこの色に観察していきます
りんごには想像以上の豊富な色があるんです
私たちが使う専門家が使う色見本帳というのがあるんですが
自然界には実はあまたと色があるにも関らず
色見本帳には限りがあるんです赤の色十色ぐらいでしょうか
探している色が見つからない
色が抜け落ちているんです
それは誰かが決めた色だからです
実は皆さん紙であれ文字であれ
みなさんが使っているペンであれノートであれ誰かがデザインしているんです
高評価されたものは誰かがデザインしています普段何気に使っているものというのは誰
かがデザインしているんです
作り方を作る
学生たちはこのりんごの色を1人100食昼食抽出していきます
自分の色見本帳を作ってみよう20人の学生で約2千食の様が見つかります
黙々と彼らは色を見つけていきます
このように色見本帳をどんどんどんどん学生たちが作っていきます
この色見本を集めて一つのリンゴ色見本帳というものを作っていきます
世界でこんなに赤の多い色見本帳があるでしょうか
そしてリンゴを中心にした色見本帳が世界にあるでしょうか
りんごの色をもう一度チェックし直します
りんご色見本帳実際の色
関西の色あなただけのよ
自然の摂理に学ぶ
りんご教科書
学生たちに初めにコンテンツというものを配っていきます
この事業のすべての内容と目的をまずはじめに知らせます
ゴールを知らせます
そして翌週には彼らのワークショップの資料を配布していきます
彼らは黙々とそれを集めていきます
自分の作品とクラス全員の作品のダイジェストがそこにファイリングされていきます
自分とみんなといった形で作品がファイリングされます
多様な考え方や技術に彼らは教師が何を言わなくても自分の立っている位置に気づき
ます
授業の終了時にはワークショップのすべてを記録した自分ごとの
教科書が出来上がってきます
デザインの新しい教科書を作る
プロセスを振り返る
オープンエデュケーション
教育を車体に開いていきます
事業で
やってるっていうのはほとんどに30名の方です
それを今日のような公園で多くの人にメッセージしていきます
そして出版化しますそして研究書化していきます
実は大阪芸術大学の図書館内にリンゴデザイン研究所というものが昨年4月に開設され
ました
あここにおられる皆さんが自由に入ってオープンエデュケーションで見ていただくこと
ができます
先ほどお話ししたヒモのことや雷色のことやら
まあこれも3つしかありません残りの11のプログラムもすべてここに入っています
そしてここにはテクノロジーを使って ipad を使って色の抽出をすることができ
ます
この学生たちと一緒に抽出した色が床全面に敷き詰められています
2800色の色が床全面を覆っています
学生たちは考え方に触れていきます
そして
遊びながら学んでいきます
海外からも多くの方が来られます情報に引き込まれていく
語れるもの作っ
デザインをいかに語っていくかということを彼らに伝えます
そして併設した別の教室が作られています
分かりやすさの設計
そして日英中韓といった4カ国語でこの授業の内容が
世界に広がっていっています
まとめえっ
理解ここが愚かすおろそかなケースが極めてを
観察知ってるつもりが最も危険です
想像仮説を立てる
仮説をたてると急に留まらない列車に乗ってしまってビューンと言っちゃう人がいます
分解する再構築をしていきます
編集これでいけるぞとなったら物語化していきます
可視化理念が動き出していきます
すべてのプロセスで気づきを探していきます
月に気づく
パティルデザ
暮らしに寄り添う
人と話す
社会の課題を探す
みんなの笑顔を想像する
喜びを綺麗する
理念を可視化させる
それがデザインです
ありがとうございました
[拍手]